our uh policy uh the uh economic and  migration partnership uh with rwanda uh  that we have uh engaged upon and now  under a huge amount of attack and not  least from uh from from lawyers what is  happening uh with the attempt to  undermine the rwanda policy uh is that  they are i'm afraid uh undermining  everything that we're trying to do to  support safe and legal routes for people  to come to the uk and to oppose the  illegal and dangerous routes that is  what we are trying to do that is the  essence of of our policy and i think  that uh what the criminal gangs are  doing and what the  those who effectively are abetting the  work of the criminal gangs are doing is  undermining people's uh confidence in  the safe and legal system undermining  people's general acceptance of of  immigration